>>> THERE WAS A VERY
CONSEQUENTIAL VOTE THIS WEEK IN
THE U.S. SENATE, REPUBLICANS
ALONG WITH TWO DEMOCRATS, JOE
MANCHIN AND KYRSTEN SINEMA
BLOCKED THE JOHN LEWIS VOTING
RIGHTS ACT.
THAT BILL WOULD HAVE UPDATED THE
1965 VOTING RIGHTS ACT THAT WAS
GUTTED BY THE SUPREME COURT AND
WOULD HAVE EXPANDED ELECTION
ACCESS ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO
COUNTER SOME 33 NEW LAWS IN 19
REPUBLICAN LED STATES, LAWS THAT
ARE DESIGNED A LOT OF VOTING
EXPERTS SAY TO SUPPRESS MINORITY
VOTES.
AFTER THE JOHN LEWIS VOTING
RIGHTS ACT WAS DEFEATED, SINEMA
SHOOK HANDS WITH REPUBLICAN
SENATORS BEFORE THE VOTE SENATE
REPUBLICAN LEADER MITCH
McCONNELL TOLD REPORTERS
MINORITY VOTERS HAD NOTHING TO
FEAR WITH ALL OF THESE NEW
RESTRICTIONS CROPPING UP ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
>> WHAT'S YOUR MESSAGE FOR
VOTERS OF COLOR WHO ARE
CONCERNED THAT WITHOUT THE JOHN
LEWIS VOTING RIGHTS ACT THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO VOTE IN
THE MIDTERM.
>> THE CONCERN IS MISPLACED
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS, AFRICAN AMERICAN
VOTERS ARE VOTING IN JUST AS
HIGH A PERCENTAGE AS AMERICANS.
>> NOW, McCONNELL HAS SAID SINCE
ALL OF THIS THAT HE MISSPOKE
THERE, BUT THAT DID NOT CONVINCE
THE COUNTLESS CITIZENS ON SOCIAL
MEDIA WHO STARTED
THE #MITCHPLEASE AND POSTED
PICTURES WITH THE MESSAGE WE ARE
AMERICANS.
PERHAPS MANY PEOPLE REMEMBER
WHAT McCONNELL AND OTHER GOP
LEADERS SAID BACK IN 2006, NOT
THAT LONG AGO, WHEN EVERY
REPUBLICAN IN THE SENATE VOTED
TO REAUTHORIZE THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT AND IT PASSED, AT THAT TIME,
98-0.
>> ONE OF MY FAVORITE SAYINGS
THAT MANY OF US USE FROM TIME TO
TIME, IF IT AIN'T BROKE DON'T
FIX IT, AND THIS IS A GOOD PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT HAS SERVED
AN IMPORTANT PURPOSE OVER MANY,
MANY YEARS, AND THIS LANDMARK
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WILL
CONTINUE TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE,
NOT ONLY IN THE SOUTH BUT FOR
ALL OF AMERICA AND FOR ALL OF
US, WHETHER WE'RE AFRICAN
AMERICANS OR NOT.
>> I HOPE 25 YEARS FROM NOW IT
CAN BE SAID THAT THERE WILL BE
NO NEED FOR THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT BECAUSE THINGS HAVE CHANGED
FOR THE BETTER.
>> IT WOULD BE NICE IF THERE
WERE NO NEED FOR A VOTING RIGHTS
ACT AS 2006 SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM JUST SAID, BUT CONSIDER
WHAT'S BEEN TAKING PLACE IN
THESE REPUBLICAN STATE HOUSES.
FOR STARTERS, THE NEW VOTING
RESTRICTIONS PASSED IN THOSE 19
GOP-LED STATES HAVE BEEN
PREDICATED ON THE BIG LIE THAT
THE ELECTION WAS RIGGED.
IT WASN'T.
WE ALL KNOW THAT NOW, AND IF
YOU'RE STILL SAYING IT WAS
RIGGED, PLEASE GET HELP.
THEN THERE ARE THE VARIOUS
PROVISIONS IN THE STATE LAWS
THAT APPEAR TO TARGET VOTERS
WITH COLOR THAT OFFER LESS TIME
TO REQUEST AN ABSENTEE BALLOT
AMONG OTHER WAYS THAT MAKE IT
HARDER TO VOTE.
GEORGIA FAMGSLY PASS ADD LAW
THAT THREATENS TO PUNISH PEOPLE
WHO HAND OUT WATER AND SNACKS TO
VOTERS WAITING IN LONG LINES.
AIN'T THAT A PEACH.
STUDIES IN RECENT YEARS HAVE
SHOWN THAT VOTING LINES ARE
LONGER IN MINORITY COMMUNITIES
AND TEXAS, THE STATE'S
REPUBLICAN PARTY TWEETED THE
QUIET PART OUT LOUD SAYING
RECENTLY IF YOU CAN WAIT IN LINE
FOR A COVID TEST, YOU CAN WAIT
IN LINE TO ROTE.
THEN THERE ARE MORE RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS IN PLACES LIKE
FLORIDA WHERE GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS IS PROPOSING AN
ELECTION POLICE FORCE.
>> TO ENSURE THAT ELECTIONS ARE
CONDUCTED IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
RULE OF LAW, I PROPOSE AN
ELECTION INTEGRITY UNIT WHOSE
SOLE FOCUS WILL BE THE
ENFORCEMENT OF FLORIDA'S
ELECTION LAWS.
THIS WILL FACILITATE THE
FAITHFUL ENFORCEMENT OF ELECTION
LAWS AND WILL PROVIDE FLORIDIANS
WITH THE CONFIDENCE THAT THEIR
VOTE WILL MATTER.
>> WHICH IS WILD BECAUSE
DeSANTIS WAS BRAGGING RIGHT
AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION THAT
FLORIDA WAS A MODEL FOR THE
NATION WHEN IT COMES TO RUNNING
ELECTIONS.
>> PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY LOOKING
AT FLORIDA AND ASKING THE
QUESTION WHY CAN'T THESE STATES
BE MORE LIKE FLORIDA.
>> WHY CAN'T THESE STATES BE
MORE LIKE FLORIDA, HE ASKED.
GEORGIA REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR DAVID PERDUE WANTS TO
BE MORE LIKE DeSANTIS.
HE'S ALSO PROPOSING AN ELECTION
POLICE FORCE SAYING IN A
STATEMENT THE PURPOSE OF THIS
LAW ENFORCEMENT UNIT IS TO GIVE
GEORGIANS CONFIDENCE THAT ONLY
LEGAL VOTES WILL BE COUNTED, AND
THAT ANYONE WHO TRIES TO
INTERFERE WITH OUR ELECTIONS
WILL BE ARRESTED AND PROSECUTED,
BUT WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN TO THE
MOST EGREGIOUS PART YET AND
THAT'S THE ONGOING EFFORTS TO
PLACE THE MOST TRUMPY
REPUBLICANS, THE SAME POSITIONS
THAT PRESIDE OVER OUR ELECTIONS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE LIKE
MARK FINSHIP WHO WAS THE
TRUMP-BACKED GOP CANDIDATE FOR
SECRETARY OF STATE IN ARIZONA.
HE HAS SUPPORTED QANON
CONSPIRACY THETHEORIES.
>> I LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY
THAT WE SET ASSIGN AN IR
REDEEMABLY FLAWED ELECTION.
THAT'S THE ELECTION OF 2020.
WITH ALL THE EVIDENCE WE HAVE,
THE ARIZONA ELECTION SHOULD BE
DECERTIFIED BY THE -- WITH CAUSE
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
>> DONALD TRUMP WHO LOOKS LIKE
HE'S RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT OR
PRETENDING TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT,
HONESTLY, WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE,
SOUNDS PRETTY INTERESTED IN WHO
WILL BE COUNTING THE VOTES NEXT
TIME AROUND.
>> WE HAVE TO BE A LOT SHARPER
THE NEXT TIME WHEN IT COMES TO
COUNTING THE VOTE.
THERE'S A FAMOUS STATEMENT,
SOMETIMES THE VOTE COUNTER IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN THE
CANDIDATE.
WE CAN'T LET THAT EVER HAPPEN
AGAIN.
THEY HAVE TO GET TOUGHER AND
SMARTER.
>> IF RON DeSANTIS WANTS TO PUT
THAT ELECTION POLICE FORCE TO
GOOD USE, HE MIGHT CONSIDER
SENDING THEM OVER TO MAR-A-LAGO,
YOU KNOW, JUST ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS ABOUT AN ATTEMPTED
COUP.
YES, OFFICER RON, I'D LIKE TO
REPORT AN INSURRECTION, THE ONE
ON JANUARY 6th.
BUT ALL OF THIS IS WHY THE
VARIOUS INVESTIGATIONS INTO
TRUMP'S ACTIONS LEADING UP TO
AND DURING THE JANUARY 6th
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL ARE SO
MONUMENTALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT
NOW.
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE'S
PROBE IS MOVING CLOSER TO TRUMP
FOCUSING ON THE BIG NAMES IN HIS
INNER CIRCLE, PEOPLE LIKE HIS
DAUGHTER IVANKA TRUMP WHO
RECEIVED A LETTER FROM THE
COMMITTEE ASKING FOR INFORMATION
ABOUT HER FATHER'S ACTIONS IN
THE DAYS LEADING UP TO AND ON
JANUARY 6th, AND NEN THERE'S
RUDY GIULIANI, APPARENTLY HE DID
MORE THAN HOLD A NEWS CONFERENCE
AT THE FOUR SEASONS TOTAL
LANDSCAPING COMPANY.
HE WAS LEADING EFFORT TO HAVE
BOGUS ELECTORS SEND IN FAKE
CERTIFICATES TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES FALSELY CLAIMING TRUMP
WON SEVEN BATTLEGROUND STATES.
GIULIANI SEEMS TO HAVE FREE TIME
ON HIS HANDS THESE DAYS AS HE
APPEARS TO BE SELLING
AUTOGRAPHED 9/11 T-SHIRTS FOR
$911.
RUDY NEVER FORGETS HOW TO MAKE A
BUCK.
>>> SOME ON THE FAR RIGHT
APPARENTLY WANT YOU TO FORGET
THE SACRIFICES MADE BY JOHN
LEWIS AND OTHER ICONS OF THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
DURING THEIR EPIC STRUGGLE FOR
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE BALLOT BOX
IN THE 1960s, STATES LIKE
FLORIDA ARE ATTEMPTING TO LIMIT
DISCUSSIONS OF RACE IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS, BARRING INSTRUCTION
THAT MAKES STUDENTS FEEL
DISCOMFORT, GUILT, ANGUISH OR
ANY OTHER FORM OF PSYCHOLOGICAL
DISTRESS ON ACCOUNT OF HIS OR
HER RACE, COLOR, SEX, OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN.
ARE THEY ALLOWED TO TEACH KIDS
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED TO JOHN
LEWIS, OR MIGHT THAT HURT THEIR
FEELINGS?
WELL, THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED TO
JOHN LEWIS, ON MARCH 7th, 1965
WHEN HE AND OTHER CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS MARCHED ACROSS THE
EDMUND PETTUS BRIDGE IN ALABAMA.
THEY WERE BEATEN BY POLICE
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY BELIEVED IN
SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS EQUAL
ACCESS TO THE VOTING BOOTH.
LEWIS SUFFERED A CRACKED SKULL
ON THAT DAY, WHICH BECAME KNOWN
AS BLOODY SUNDAY.
LEWIS SPOKE ABOUT THE STRUGGLE
DURING HIS ADDRESS TO THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION IN 2012.
>> NOT TOO LONG AGO PEOPLE STOOD
IN UNMOVABLE LINES.
THEY HAD TO PASS A SO-CALLED
LITERACY TEST.
PAY A POLL TAX.
ON ONE OCCASION A MAN WAS ASKED
TO TAP THE NUMBER IN A BAR OF
SOAP.
ON ANOTHER OCCASION, ONE WAS
ASKED TO COUNT THE JELLYBEANS IN
A JAR, ALL TO KEEP THEM FROM
CASTING THEIR BALLOT.
I'VE SEEN THIS BEFORE.
I LIVED THIS BEFORE.
TOO MANY PEOPLE STRUGGLED,
SUFFERED, AND DIED TO MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR EVERY AMERICAN TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE.
>> JOHN LEWIS USED TO TALK ABOUT
THE VIRTUES OF GOOD TROUBLE,
SOMETHING TELLS ME THE
POLITICIANS STANDING IN THE WAY
OF VOTING RIGHTS ARE ABOUT TO
GET A LESSON IN WHAT THAT'S ALL
ABOUT.
PERHAPS THESE EFFORTS TO STOP
THE VOTE WILL BACKFIRE AND
ACTUALLY MOTIVATE PEOPLE TO
STAND IN LONG LINES TO CAS